1 тисячі п'ятнадцятій українська
економіка звільнилася вона може 15 років
сотки витог злих до піднялася парта хіба
блокада на подібний і завантажу економічному
відро печіння в Україні і не кінчай pfc
україна нині
блисну задуху і петля абсолютно на ньому
вірні і ту ж глибоку рецесію як ви
знаєте про 2014 2015 уроки ми витратили та
адже ми ж 20 сотки в нашого ввп
пластир
лами пачино їм його душу в готель ми нову
руку наш ввп ж розріз на дві цілих три
десятих вид сотка звичайно для нас
тигони товстий нам треба просто тиж вище
seguro que ми прогнози вали зрощення
ранку та вид сотка років через недавній
шляхів через блокаду на донбасі натиснули
мвд ра там один вид соток нашого ввп
тілу руку теж дарма що зі зростання не стану
ви вдома чуючи 2 сотки
анни 3 а лація реліз точно під x-men
саду жуйки розумом і для інвесторів
інфляція 22 сотки
якийсь продався і скоро ти та та так
адже й публіка у ставку пройшла уроку
було 14 адже сотки як ви збираєтеся
право блювати інвестицій
shaquille коробки у тому на початку
минуло ву руку ми за проводив і
абсолютно нову монетарну політику c
політика targa туго не інфляції і манула
уроку ми досягли своєю метою 12900 ким
Те ву руку нашим це девід адже сотки в
наступна ось і будуть 6 сотки
а з роком ми модему інфляції лиж знову
адже сотки ми моєму абсолютно читку дати
інфляції на тенденцію протез не забуває
а ще у 2015 у нас було інфляція 43
сотки теж девід з'явиться такого інфляція
для нас не аби кого не хоче відібрати у
чого вода сили свою монотонну кулі
таку карту національна валюта все
шаблони лося балата фінансових інституті
моріс банк рутила через шлюб руку
капіталу ніж гра по вашому обидва живота
можливості бізнесу для російських банків
аджиїв не ділянки на українському ринку
може дати відповідь сотки просто фол я
абсолютно ви абсолютно праві вони сир
і там дізналася
залишилося а у сіті припиню цьому тепер
ситуація власна на США
ми вже провели аналіз я кістки активі то
стрес-тест у всіх українських банків та та
банку ж провали
рекапіталізацію своїх банківських
установки потрібними ситуація в рази краща
і відомо вимиє і рацію рахунку
російських банків російські банки
виставили на продаж свої дочірні
підприємства тріска на 3
а зараз он і на фінальній стадії
вивчай на нашому та до гаранту вати
державним російським банкам шивани будуть
під контролем
на за знов там ось skoda через
спадщина чий аполітичний не spoke та
завищувати ринок професіонал ситуація для
людей в україні ви самі ще говорити
фінансово не і мвф катастрофічно не
орхідні так то люди поттер підвид таке
політика фрс ти повноти або dann ist
народжує у edition pro заощадження нашу та
макро фінансові стабільності макро
фінансово стабільність пари дубова для
нашого економічно зростання ви знаєте
потрібно у я випуск без відстані ввп чиї
досягнення гарно жити а для нашого
населення